It's because the bloody intellectual
leftists have never apologized for their
complicity in the catastrophes of the
20th century.
The Germans apologized.
Sorry about the Nazis.
Well,
the left wing intellectuals,
they say,
well,
that was real.
That wasn't real Marxism.
It's like,
oh,
okay.
How many carbs does have to pile up
around you before you're willing to
question your beloved ideological
presuppositions and face your resentment
and your narcissism and your desire for
destruction.
You don't like people anyways.
The planet has too many of them,
so like a nice warm.
I cleared out.
Well then all the plants can grow again.
You know the club of Rome,
when they talked about the population
explosion that was going to wipe out the
planet by the year 2000,
they say outright that human beings are
a cancer on the planet.
Lots of people think that.
It's like,
oh boy,
next put the atom bomb a phone in your
hands.
Human beings are a cancer on the planet.
What a hell of a thing to say?
You're saying that to a four year old.
I saw bloody professor at Queen's
University.
Tell a whole room full of 18 year olds
that if they had an ethical fiber in
their body,
they wouldn't have any kids or they only
have one because all they're doing is
going out there and raping the planet.
It's like,
what?
You know,
what the hell?
What?
I don't understand that.
It's like human beings are hard on the
planet,
but it's pretty damn hard on us in
return.
You know?
It's like we're just sort of trying not
to die to miserably and we make a bit of
a mess.
Well,
doing it.
It's like,
yeah,
Chris,
we've only known for 50 years that we
were disrupting the oceans.
How fast do you think we can learn in
100 years ago,
Thomas Huxley,
who was a great biologist,
said,
the oceans are so plentiful.
It was not a chance we could ever put a
dent in them.
So there's only 100 years ago.
Fifty years ago we thought,
Oh man,
there's more of us and we're better at
this than we thought.
So like,
okay,
how fast do you expect people to learn?
You know,
one generation,
one year,
we're trying to do our best.
Most.
Most people are trying to do their best
and some people are trying to do their
worst,
but most people are trying to do their
best and so we should have a little
compassion,
a little sympathy for human beings
instead of considering ourselves like
raping patriarchal,
oppressive destroyers of the world.
She's this.